depuis le 17 octobre 2019 le liban est
rythmée par des manifestations sans
précédent qui secoue le pays pour
dénoncer le système politique
confessionnel la corruption et les
difficultés économiques
au début de ce mouvement la police
libanaise avait été saluée pour son
pacifisme et sa non violence envers les
manifestants une police qui avait
publiquement exprimé son engagement à
protéger le droit de rassemblement des
citoyens
mais depuis quelques semaines le ton est
monté entre les manifestants et les
forces de l'ordre qui n'hésitent plus à
faire usage de la force
une situation que human rights watch a
décrit comme un usage excessif de la
force et cet usage excessif de la force
il se fait avec une certaine french
touch est pas comme on les aime car
certaines des armes utilisées sont de
fabrication française et ce sont les
manifestants eux-mêmes qui sur les
réseaux sociaux révèle les armes
utilisées celles de l'entreprise
française al cettex alors pour ceux qui
ne connaissent pas al cettex est une
filiale de la multinationale etienne
lacroix et qui a également fourni des
gaz lacrymogènes au gouvernement de
bahreïn al ses textes à qui l'on doit
également entre autres les dangereuses
grenade glff 4 et gm de l utilisées par
les forces de l'ordre françaises
au liban les grenades c'est m6 et j'ai
un fond utilisées elles contiennent
toutes deux sicap sud qui se dispersent
après leur lancement permettant aux gaz
lacrymogènes de couvrir une plus grande
surface
les lettres s à eux lisible sur les
photos renvoie au nom complet de
l'entreprise société d'armement et
d'études elle ses textes
ensuite il ya les lanceurs de grenades
notamment le couguar 12 qui est un
imposant dispositif avec un lanceur de
grenade à plusieurs canons montées sur
les véhicules des forces de l'ordre une
arme pouvant tirer au coup par coup ou
par salves de 4 ou 12 grenades
plusieurs internautes libanais ont
également publié des photos de douilles
siglé s apl pour société d'applications
des procédés le
fèvre c'est doux noir peut entraîner des
blessures mortelles si elle est tirée
sur une personne à moins de 35 m il faut
savoir qu'à l'international altex
rayonne et réalise 50% du chiffre
d'affaires à l'exportation
une société qui engrange des dizaines de
millions d'euros de commandes
la france comme une grande partie de la
communauté internationale s'était
montrée plutôt prudente face aux
soulèvements en cours au liban le
ministère des affaires étrangères a
appelé à réaliser les réformes
nécessaires afin de permettre le
rétablissement de l'économie libanaise
la france elle a d'ailleurs accordé un
prêt de matériel pour un montant de 400
millions d'euros aux forces de l'ordre
en février 2019 l'armement militaire
français a encore de beaux jours devant
lui au pays du cèdre
[Musique]